now you first read the script or was it
about it that stood out to you I you
know I was like I saw Amos up against a
pretty big hill you know he just
survived an accident and he'd lost
basically every friend he knew and
worked with and he's put against the
situation having to testify against
negligence you know a human error we're
all really capable of human error the
moral choices of having to protect those
men's and and their dignity and and then
also you know these companies they are
the only economical infrastructure
provided for these these coal mining
towns that no one gives to about you
know is then so I it was really strong
it was really honest and it was had a
lot of heart and I selfishly took that
on myself
how much kind of responsibility comes
with a role like that then uh you know I
did a lot of work I I studied with a guy
at NYU physical therapy again I'm Mike
tranquilly who you know we just started
tossing ideas around what you know what
does carbon oxide do to you for 48 hours
you know small strokes liver failure
heart failure you know you're pretty
ravaged after something like this and so
I really put in as much attention to it
as possible cuz I really deserved it
I tell me a little bit more about the
guys you're working with on the phone
I'm working with that handsome
um he's great Jacob Laughlin then kind
of took it my own responsibility to be
his big brother whether he likes it or
not
liz is phenomenal to work with Sarah
just wrote a really good script off the
bat and I think she just really
attracted a lot of talent you know even
from people driving from Virginia to
West Virginia you know eight hours just
to work for nothing and have a good time
so I I'm just really over the moon about
a lot of them we know you've got lots
more coming from you as well tell us a
little bit about what's on the horizon
um well get these two films here um I
have David Fincher's gone girl is coming
out we'll see if I make it into the
Malick movie I don't know that's the
whole thing and then I've got walk among
the tombstones I'm directing this short
story about Sam Shepard called the
peacock killer it's kind of strangely
odd and I've got a film written of be
directing called Uncle Sam and that's a
killer films so we'll see you know
hopefully I'll keep paying rent keeping
busy aren't you very video Matt we're um
finally can we tell these a little bit
about what it's been like working with
both David Fincher and terrence malick
on those films
oh man you can't really compare the two
I mean they're just brilliant in their
own right aesthetically opposite side
the ball you know they they really do
different they're just different
filmmakers but they're good and they I
con you know the static is different
this you know it's just you play a lot
with Fincher you play a lot with with
with Terry yeah
they're amazing
you